nestled in between the skincare love
beauty spa and advani's pest control
school here in elmhurst queens is
indo-java a two-aisle mini-mart for all
things indonesian but every tuesday it
turns into the city's smallest
restaurant with truly authentic
indonesian food hi
welcome to marvel
you're in luck you got the best table in
the house this is the one
it it's also the only table
[Music]
my name is david chayadi
i'm the
owner of the
indo-java we opened indoor java 10 years
ago
every tuesday i cook right here for all
the customers
we call warrong's lassa so it means
tuesday food stall this little souprette
turned one table pop-up restaurant isn't
complete without one of the smallest
kitchens in the world our kitchen is
very tiny it's a love kitchen because
just enough for two person
[Laughter]
two people might be a stretch
it's half the size of a broom closet but
it doesn't stop dewy from whipping up
classic indonesian fare like gudeg and
rendang i am
[Music]
just like the original
yummy
before there is none indonesian store
it's difficult to find the ingredient
from indonesia and we miss the community
if we have a store the indonesian people
will come here and then we still can
talk indonesian language
that's our our dream and then now is
happen
[Music]
i'm not a professional chef i don't have
any the education chef background so i
just learned from my mom
in the restaurant the chef always hide
in the kitchen i like to talk with the
customer when i serve the food so we can
sharing the story
they always say it next week i have to
come again
[Music]
you